زياره ميدانيه مفاجئه للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين للجبهات شرقا وجنوب
اوكرانيا للمره الاولى منذ بدايه الغزو
الروسيه لاوكرانيا يتفقد بوتين قوات بلاده
في منطقتي خرسون بمناسبه عيد الفصح الذي
احتفل به الارث حسب بيان نشره الكريم من
دون ذكر تاريخ الزياره
من المهم بالنسبه الي ان اسمع رايكم حول
الوضع ان استمع اليكم واتبادل معكم
المعلومات
بوتين التقى في خرسون جنوب اوكرانيا قائد
القوات الروسيه الجويه وقاده عسكريين
كبارا اخرين لبحث الوضع في منطقتي خرسون
اللتين اعلنت موسكو ضمهما في سبتمبر
الماضي
وفي لوغانسك شرق اوكرانيا تبحث مع عسكري
هيئه اركان الحرس الوطني الروسي حول الوضع
الميداني زياره اثارت ردود فعل غاضبه في
اوكرانيا
انها جوله خاصه لمرتكب جرائم قتل جماعيه
في الاراضي المحتله والمدمره وللتلذذ
بالجرائم التي ارتكبتها القوات الروسيه
في شهر مارسا الماضي قام الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بزياره غير معلنه الى شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا في عام 2014
والى ماريوبول التي حاصرها الجيش الروسي
على مدى اشهر واستولى عليها في مايو
الماضي